think like being feminine is like giving
up control it's really hard for most
modern women yeah yeah like because
we're told to like we operate in a
masculine Society of like go out and get
it I disagree I think we operate in a
gynocentric society that puts women on a
pedestal and also bails them out of
every bad decision that we make ever and
tells us we're queens and perfect all
the time
when you say in a masculine society as
in in order to succeed in society yeah
you have to manifest and grow the things
that are traditionally masculine because
that's what's going to get the results
foreign
things so for me if I had a daughter and
she was really successful part of her
her upbringing will also know when to
play that role when to take power and
when not to whereas back then the
parents didn't even the women didn't
have that power I don't think he said it
didn't know they didn't know to tell
their daughters or they we like I didn't
learn the things I know now from my mum
because my mum necessarily didn't become
the successful woman she was when I was
young is as I got older so then when I
became successful and I realized I
understood what I really wanted and I
realized where the problem was coming
then I understood that you got a
different shape work and I think
is what does success look like to you
because to the traditional woman
successful success would look like
raising okay yeah successful women now
looks like I want to make money as much
money success to me as a single woman is
being able to give myself the life I
would wanted if I was married right but
that's because I'm single but success to
me as a married woman is being in a home
where my heart my husband I can carry
him literally on my head and he is like
my prize Jewel he's successful I rub his
back I support him mad in her DMS
no but that's why I'm saying no but
that's why I'm saying to you that some
of us women the way we behave is is also
it's just our circumstances I don't
wanna I don't want to go to work
sorry but I'm saying like it's our
choices okay so yeah well okay yeah
you can't say any girl in this room
couldn't be married at 21 22. yeah I got
married at 23 yeah yeah yeah
but what so without being an ass what
would you say to a woman who has okay
she's gone she's gone married she's gone
through those mistakes or whatever she's
come out of that marriage and everything
yes you know your children are important
blah blah blah but she wants to act
because I believe people make mistakes
and you should be given the opportunity
to correct them what would you then
advise that girl or that woman that has
accepted all her flaws that knows where
she's gone wrong and still wants to
potentially be in a home where she can
be submissive and everything is that not
possible anymore of course it's possible
oh okay yeah go on you go I mean I think
it's it's possible for sure I just think
like
you're not you're not going to get get
the same guys you could get at 22. 21
23. okay and you probably can't do
better than your baby daddy
I know you say that right and I don't
crochet that my ex or anything but I can
I think so but you know why I can not
because of not necessarily because of oh
I've got this money I'm Wiser yeah I I
understand life a lot more yeah but like
men don't care
um I think some do I think the caliber
of men that I unlocked
they don't care I don't disagree with
what you're saying I just think that the
type of man that you want you have to be
quite cognizant of the type of man that
you are like that you have to select
because I think women still have this
ideal that you're still going to get
this high value like Untouchable guy
about for most women when in reality the
type of man you have to accept isn't
going to be the type of man maybe he's
gonna have kids maybe he's going to have
yeah
because women operate on possibilities
not probabilities and there are
exceptions that could happen I mean I
would tell a girl get in the best shape
of your life so but I was gonna say I
think it's
I think that what we have to consider is
I get that like you've come out you're
in the right frame of mind to have
that's going to be conducive to the to
that life right and you've made those
mistakes whatever that's completely fair
I completely get that the reality is
it's not that you couldn't get a man
that maybe you feel Worthy
but the top guy right there are other
women out there who maybe had the
mindset you have now
before you made those mistakes okay okay
so those women who have that mindset
1921-22 right the mindset you have now
maybe they know those things because of
the way they've grown up whatever reason
they are just in a higher chance to get
that top guy
question yeah how many women on the age
of 20 to 25 would you say do you think
have that mindset now in the modern day
times
do you honestly not many and that's why
not many Americans but that's why um I
don't know they say in like the red pill
that to date girls between like 25 to
like 28 because it's kind of like before
they're running out of time and they're
desperate
I am not interested
I mean but I I mean I don't I don't know
I don't know I'll be honest I think I
think the the the women who have that
armored
by them but who have that mindset if
they have the mindset of where their
priority because here's the thing if
your priority when you're younger right
is to
have a family if that's your priority
most women who have that protein that
young they get married that young and
they have that now yeah yeah I think
what happens is and you know it's just
the way it is in the modern era
more women are choosing to prioritize
their career in their 20s well not only
that
women who are bitter who didn't advise
younger girls to follow along the same
path as them so you'll get the single
mothers women that have been [ __ ] over
by men because of the wrong decisions
that they've made in topic as they go
for and then when they when they talk to
younger women they say oh you know live
your life just go out there sleep around
and when you get older you'll find the
right guys I've never gotten that advice
ever oh listen so the way I have I no
because older older girls like lie to
you oh wow yeah but also like again
that's just like so toxic like you're
acting out of your trauma you know that
what do you mean acting out of your
trauma so most of us do that
okay
um but like acting out your trauma is
basically like okay so say you went
through something bad right like I don't
know you got with someone and you had a
kid with them and and they left you
right and then you then usually women
leave but yeah yeah okay cool in this
scenario the met the man left
um unless say
then that person then tells their
daughter just go out do what you want
blah blah don't get a man blah blah
right that's acting out of your trauma
because something bad happened to you
and because of that bad experience that
has now shaped your advice
okay do you hear how you like tell that
story though it's like something bad
happened to you instead of I made that
decision like for some reason with women
whenever we tell stories like it's we
always take the accountability off of us
[Music]
um
you guys talk what is your submission
cost yeah
um
I would say
um
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible